The world is awash in data.
It's growing in exponential rates.
People have even coined the term big
data to refer to this phenomenon,
but can't quite agree
on what that means.
What separates big data from what
I guess you could call everything
else little data.
Caesar Hidalgo at MIT's media lab says
that to qualify for this distinction,
data must be big in size,
resolution, and scope.
To reframe this idea in a way that is
directly relevant to transforming health
care delivery systems,
data must represent many patients and
providers, must do so in great detail,
and must be combined with
other data to give a context within
which that care is delivered, and
the external rules and policies within
which that delivery system must operate.
The data must, in summary,
be sufficient to represent the behavior
of the complex adaptive health
care system we've been discussing.
Where in the health IT landscape
might you best go to find big data
as we just defined it for health care?
Would that be in an enterprise EHR for
a major health system,
all the installations of a specific
EMR in a state or region,
a service area health information
exchange, or none of these?